und wir haben jetzt die endgültige
bestätigung dass das zitat der kanzlerin
noch emotionaler war als wir zunächst
geglaubt haben sie hat zitat gesagt ich
lasse mir nicht anhängen dass sich
kinder quälen oder arbeitnehmerrechte
missachte also das ist ein zitat in
einer emotional i tät düsen wie wir es
von der kanzlerin nicht kennen ja genau
und was ist jetzt das problem daran ist
kein problem daran ich finde es nur ein
spannendes zitat und wichtig zu sagen
wie dieses zitat da hinter
verschlossenen türen tatsächlich
gefallen ist und es zeigt wie viel ich
mächtig diskutiert die unsere kanzlerin
wird nicht verschont auch mit dem
problem in diesem land und das ist doch
erst mal gut und wenn sie nicht national
reagiert dann wenn immer geschrieben
warum reagiert die nicht warum sie nicht
und jetzt ist sie mal emotional wird ist
das auch wieder und ich glaube nicht
nein ich habe nicht gesagt dass es
falsch ist sondern nur darauf
hingewiesen dass die recherchen von mir
und den kollegen ergeben hat dass das
wort kämen auch gefallen wir sind bild
und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren